yesterday Yale University said it would
kick out any student who was found to
have falsified their application they'll
kick him out and the whole story really
when you think about it it's about power
and it's about privilege I wanted to get
a different perspective on it so I've
asked a good friend of the show to
comment here tonight he's one of the
stars from the hit show blackish please
welcome our friend Deon Cole
thanks Conan yeah now have you been
following Dee on the the college
application scandal oh very closely okay
a lot of folks were shocked to learn
that rich people pay someone to get
their kids into better schools yeah it's
true it was no it was really shocking it
was yeah it was yeah but you know who
wasn't shocked black people know I can
I can yeah I can see that I heard some
parents paid doctors to say their kids
had a Dede so they get extra time to
take the college tests bribing a doctor
to get a privileged kid into college
that is stunning news but you know who
wasn't stun black people
idea and I see where you're going with
this Coenen did you know if a black kid
and a white kid do the same thing wrong
in school the black kid will be
suspended three times more often than
the white kid that's that's astonishing
oh it is astonishing and you know who
wasn't astonished
[Applause]
Thank You Dion you make a very valid
point Helen did you also know that
there's places in America where a black
person can get fired for wearing their
natural hair I didn't know that well
I'll tell you who did know that brother
good thing y'all find us here
[Applause]
yes Deon that's definitely an issue that
that needs to be addressed yes Conan the
most elite high school in New York City
has eight hundred and ninety five
freshmen slots and this year only nine
of them went to black people show me
black people
that is correct Conan now show me not
answers I get it blacks are still being
treated unfairly I'm glad I was able to
use my show to bring this to people's
attention me too
I just wish your show was watched by
more say it has some guy in the rafters
black people yeah thank you thank you
very much Deon my pleasure and thank you
Deon
make sure you see me at Alabama this
weekend at the stardome
[Applause]